welcome back to the real rejects i'm
greg alba i'm john humphrey we're going
to watch today from new rock stars
obi-wan kenobi trailer easter eggs and
breakdown i watched this trailer like
four more times last night so many
little clues we missed eric's not
pointing them all out for us i already
know them all figured all that myself
no this will be just for me then i will
be enlightened by them leave a like
people new rock stars is the bomb let's
do this
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for obi-wan kenobi or should i
say
because duel of the bates is back in our
ears and all of the ghosts of obi-wan's
past are back to haunt him as he strives
to protect a young luke skywalker ahead
of his rematch with darth vader i loved
this trailer and i'm gonna break it down
frame by frame because it is filled with
awesome star wars easter eggs it just
includes subtle details that you just
might have overlooked so let's go
the fight is done
[Music]
we lost the trailer opens with anakin
skywalker's favorite stuff sand it
coarsely and roughly and irritatingly
gets everywhere under the twin sons of
tatooine in the music there's how they
are magical
[Music]
the great john williams is returning to
the music for this series and this riff
is played on a celeste which john
williams loves to muse like in his
series
oh is that what that is
that is beautiful if you remember the
opening shot of the last jedi teaser
there's a little riff there
yes
[Music]
i just had this image in my head of john
williams going by his piano i'm going i
need something new
[Laughter]
actually the music in the first section
of this trailer is john williams theme
from revenge of the sith called the
battle of the heroes
[Music]
just showing how after all these years
obi-wan is still haunted by the memory
of his friend's betrayal and what he had
to do to him obi-wan writes an eop a
tattooing animal first scene in phantom
menace
[Music]
yes
yes
but also the steed obi-wan was seen
in the final scene of revenge of the
sith this series was much more difficult
years later in the year nine bby that's
nine years before the events of a new
hope this is the middle period when
obi-wan an exile under the alias of ben
kenobi keeps a watchful eye over young
luke skywalker keeping him hidden from
the empire as a farm boy living with his
uncle owen and his aunt peru he's
supposed to age in just like 10 years
into alec mcginnis yep it's going to be
a rough life on tattoo
that is insane yeah
yeah he's gotta get all ancient by then
now various other star wars titles over
the years have touched on obi-wan's time
during this period saving young luke's
life at various points as owen would
warn him to stay away and then actually
at one point saving owen from black
personality and that wookie who just
showed up in bubba bed giving bk that
scar that we saw in his head and then at
another point later than the show when
lucas 12 he saved him from a crate
dragon actually see obi-wan walking into
town and slicing off a piece of meat
this actually might be a slab of crate
dragon meat from one that he had
butchered obi-wan laments the fight is
done
[Music]
we lost
yeah you'll notice this voice sounds a
bit echoey here as if he might be
speaking these words while in a
meditative state communicating perhaps
with yoda or maybe with the ghost of
qui-gon
yoda told obi-wan that he would teach
him how to reconnect with the ghost of
his old master an old friend has learned
the path
to immortality
your old master
yes how to commune with him i will teach
you so let us all pray liam neeson
returns to the series to impart this
very particular set of skills moving on
well in the club wars he does at one
point reconnect with qui-gon what is
that planet called that fail what a
mortise
dammit
damn it all in hell i'm done with this
you are the star wars expert yeah that's
what i know failure fake nerd and i do
think there was actually a deleted scene
that you could see of yoda communing
with qui-gon that might be the exact
clip on youtube
yoda commuting
so obi-wan watches over the lars
homestead looking just as it did in a
new hope with owen and brew even wearing
pretty much the same outfits that they
wore in that first film actually this is
dark but they are standing in the same
exact spot where luke will later find
their coordinates oh my goodness no
torch the home meanwhile 10 year old
luke plays as a pilot it looks like he's
actually wearing pod racing goggles and
the way he pantomimes operating the
controls and leans just looks so much
like young anakin piloting during that
pod race and right as obi-wan pushes in
on luke the moment he zooms in on him
john williams battle of the heroes theme
transitions so smoothly into the classic
force theme
stay hidden
let's move on
[Music]
best songs choir vocals lucasfilm got
dusted
to hunting jedi
oh baby what a needle drop john williams
doula the fates is of course best known
from phantom menace
[Music]
but the music was always bigger than
just darth maul's theme because it's
really come back throughout star wars
titles or the lyrics of the song john
williams translated an old welsh poem
called battle of the trees into the
sanskrit language he wanted to frame
this duel as a kind of pagan religious
ceremony almost like the spirits of both
sides of this conflict the jedi and the
sith shrieking like a greek chorus
egging on their mortal champions and
that's today
he's still being waged now as obi-wan
faces darth vader once more as he faces
the inquisitors and maybe also faces a
rematch with maul because this is set
one year after the events of soloist
star wars story which established maul
as the powerful head of the crimson dawn
crime organization now in star wars
rebels which is several years after this
maul will eventually track down obi-wan
to tatooine but this is something he
would not yet know at this point of this
show so that rematch would not go down
on tatooine but we do see obi-wan go off
world in this trailer either way maul
could simply cameo in some other scene
that would set him upon his revenge
quest in rebels at least give sam witwer
one more chance to reprise this
is so good speeds across this ocean
planet towards this fortress this is the
ocean moon of ner and this is the
fortress inquisitorious so let's talk
about the inquisitors originally the
jedi hunters from the 1987 role-playing
game inquisitors were introduced in
rebels explored further in the 2015
darth vader comics and in the jedi
fallen order game they are a squad of
four sensitive beings trained by darth
vader to hunt down jedi survivors of
order 66. they're led by the grand
inquisitor voiced in rebels by jason
isaacs and played here by rupert friend
turned rupert foe this is the one
using the mummified remains of the jedi
master luminara unduli the grand
inquisitor dies at the end of that
season there are some things far more
frightening than death
[Music]
but he was later revealed to be one of
those jedi guards in clone wars who
helped arrest ahsoka tano when she was
falsely accused of bombing the jedi
temple and then later he helped arrest
the true culprit barissafi but from that
experience he learned the flaws in the
jedi orthodoxy and that's what opened
him up to be corrupted by palpatine and
it would suggest palpatine did that to
help expedite the fall of the jedi
temple i just want to say really quick
every time there's an adaptation from an
animated character into live action
there's backlash so the first thing i
saw was backlash for grand inquisitor
it's going to always look a little
different guys it's not something we
need to throw
i always think what would it look like
if we went in reverse can you imagine if
count dooku looked like how we did in
clone wars it would look super goofy
you know you you gotta readjust here
when you're doing it in the actual live
action humanoid form it's going to look
different it's gonna have to fit the
aesthetic of the series as well now the
fortress inquisitorius is a secret
location after the inquisitors were
forced to relocate from coruscant so
that now they're really off the books
the moon of ner is actually very close
to mustafar where vader's castle now
stands their shuttles which we've seen
in concept art have a two-pronged tip
that matches the two-pronged tower of
vader's castle oh cool
the water fortress in the game fall in
order and that game reveals the
backstory of the inquisitor named the
second sister trilla suduri former
padawan to sir agenda the second sister
goes on to fight calcus and in defeat
nearly forgives her from her master but
is executed by darth vader other
inquisitors include the fifth brother
and the seventh sister from season two
of rebels who tried to kill kanan jairus
and ezra bridger and an arc that also
introduces the eighth brother an
inquisitor who'd been trying to track
down maul all three of these inquisitors
end up killed there was also the sixth
brother who had tried to kill ahsoka
tano but ahsoka defeated him taking his
blades kyber crystals and purifying them
white which is why in rebels animated
lauren season two ahsoka has those twin
white lightsabers cool all that
inquisitor all just great however how
baller of a move would it be if they
actually got calculus to be in this show
it would line up they already designed
calcus to be in the likeness of cameron
monahan so adapting him into live action
you probably wouldn't hear all those
complaints
so weird now what's wrong with this guy
though people find a way to complain
about it now if you look closely on the
fortress landing pad that looks like a
lambo class shuttle there that's the
same kind of [ __ ] vader and other
imperial vips used for transportation so
vader may be present here checking in on
to the next clip patience
jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail so the grand inquisitor
faces down what looks like a cantina
barkeep on tatooine his armor looks as
it doesn't rebels though here it has a
badge that he did not have before maybe
he's a special designation he gets from
the emperor that he loses after his
failures on this series now later in the
trailer the inquisitor riva a major
character who we're going to be
following on the show played by moses
ingram stops a runner dead in his tracks
in the same cantina and in this shot you
can see riva in the background on the
right oh and then on the left the
inquisitor with a wide head piece this
is actually the fifth brother from
rebels now in live action played by son
fast in the furious films i had no idea
that's oh justice that's so cool that he
gets to do this oh yeah that's great
just that's justice for han this is how
we get asian people finally in star wars
undertones
i'm just kidding i've had several asian
characters already yeah we've had enough
aging care we're done then we see a
skiff on tatooine transporting it looks
like workers including our man ben
kenobi just blending in i love how it
puffs out black smoke just making this
look like a really cheap polluting piece
of hardware meanwhile we hear the grand
inquisitor lecturing the key to hunting
jedi is patience i love it help what
they are their compassion leaves a trail
you know what he's kind of like is hans
landa
from inglorious bastards that's what the
speech sort of made me reminisce on
because this glass that delicious blue
milk now i know to a lot of you that
sounded like the voice of palpatine but
according to closed captioning on the
trailer it was actually the grand
inquisitor but it's a really interesting
perspective from a former jedi raised in
the jedi temple now patronizing the jedi
as a cult-like mental disorder george
lucas did originally conceive the empire
as space nazis and hear the grand
inquisitor's assessment see
i don't see
sort of ss of the empire then inside the
lower subaquatic levels of the fortress
inquisitorius riva meets with the fifth
brother and another inquisitor with
these tendrils both have on their backs
the ringed double-bladed sabers carried
by all inquisitors which allow them to
rotate the blades like a helicopter
rotor and you'll notice one of these
chairs has a tall two-pronged seat back
matching both their ships and vader's
castle so this may be vader's chair a
nice table or the chair of the grand
inquisitor with that grand inquisitor
trying to embody vader's aesthetic then
on tatooine someone is suspended on
display perhaps the fugitive that riva
chases down looking like a message to
the locals not to harbor jedi christians
i think they'd be a bit dark for star
wars i wonder if this guy is actually
being forced choked up over the ground
and left to suffocate among these
bystanders is joel edgerton returning as
owen lars sweating like a gumpton
mustapar now it seemed at first like
these acquitters might be on tattooing
looking for kenobi himself but i don't
know if they got that close i don't know
if pokemon would have been able to live
for another nine years after this rather
i think there is another force-sensitive
fugitive who fled the tatooine and just
got too close to obi-wan and this guy
that goddamn planet he would not be able
to help else risk his exposure and
endangered luke who is another force
sensitive kid the inquisitors would
probably target so perhaps while chasing
this random jedi riva then senses
another presence on this planet that
forces obi-wan to lead her off world and
try to throw
yeah that makes a lot of sense
that's a really good plot there
he cannot help it
where is
he okay here we see riva on the new
planet named daiyu described by the
writer of this series as a hong
kong-like setting with graffiti written
nightlife the neon orabesh beside riva
translates to er and then to her left as
she looks out letter spelling out milk
kind of like old man luke they love the
lactate here
the inquisitor shuttle lands on tatooine
and then a shot of imperial officer
played by indira varma aka elaria sand
from game of thrones that's where she's
from you can tell by her badge red red
red blue she is the rank of captain in
the imperial navy then that female
inquisitor interrogates a lineup on the
daiyu street you can see an orbish sign
in the background translating to haas
market and as she walks right the last
suspect on the end is a large fur
covered fella that we cut away from
quickly a wookie perhaps or an ewok
there's a smuggler then we see this
quick shot of a new droid letters on his
chest looking like they translate to ned
i'm wondering if this could be camille
nanjiani's character which would keep
with the recent star wars tradition of
comedians yeah yeah yeah yeah bridge
matt barry richard iot alan tudyk let's
not forget bill hader did bb-8 yes he
did let's not forget most iconic let's
not forget and richard pryor was r2d2
correct then the grand inquisitor fans
his lightsaber never breaking eye
contact now this bald dude does look a
bit like the same head shape as tamar
morrison aka boba fett aka every clone
and clone trooper making me wonder if
this could be a runaway clone trooper
after order that would be cool to do
and i only bring this up because there
is another shot in this trailer showing
the backside of some really banged up
looking stormtrooper armor a little too
scratched for stormtrooper armor
would this be the clone trooper armor of
rex could rex be in this show i mean i
know he wouldn't die here because rex
survived that would be so cool
screen time to make up for those two
episodes of the boba fett series i would
absolutely adore that there are some
clones who end up not being bad there's
a guy named gregor
hey this is your guy that's my guy he's
your guy his name reminds me of someone
but if you brought rex in there and rex
was in bad batch so clearly they want to
keep his presence alive and he's like
that clone outside of boba fett who
intersects throughout the series from
club wars to bad batch rebels and now to
come into live action i think that would
be a really cool call or or cody here
the fifth brother leads a squad of
stormtroopers on daiyu and yup i
translated all the orabesh on the far
right the last letters are e-t maybe the
last letters of the word market and then
the blue sign at the top of frame i
think spells out the same thing as the
other blue sign in frame gungan snacks
and then on the right side we see some
pink letters with the green border also
the same word repeated with the orange
letters in green border both spelling
out the word market and then on the far
right in orange once again milk
yeah
i dream about that space these look a
lot like the pod used by yoda in revenge
of the sith to escape to dagobah
at the moment he and obi-wan separate to
their respective exiles which tells us
that we may see flashbacks
of the sith and flashbacks to the clone
wars era then we see a black major hand
touching a symbol chalked on a wall this
is the sigil of the jedi order the saber
flanked by the wings this actually may
be riva finding a jedi hiding place
maybe the jedi have used these markings
to signal to each other and to keep the
hope alive then in an alley reeva stares
down a gunman's helicopter
zobie one not wanting to out himself yet
by using his lightsaber instead opting
for the blaster so uncivilized i love
how the backlighting casts a long shadow
in front of a riva which gives her just
as fearsome edge but also suggests that
her opponent will have the light in his
eyes for this duel then we see a quick
rooftop shootout that looks like obi-wan
engaging with some blasters coming from
multiple different directions i do like
the detail of the laundry being hung up
to dry now they said they based daiyu on
hong kong and fun fact at mission
possible 3 j.j abrams actually had to
digitally remove shots of hanging
laundry in shanghai because local film
distributors didn't want shanghai to
look poor but interesting
deborah chow leaves the laundry in then
an overhead shot shows a vent releasing
these green birds i'm not really sure
but the best-known green bird in star
wars is mori the female convoy who
befriended ahsoka tano with a spiritual
connection to the daughter the mystical
deity of mortis it is called mortis
but until now i don't think we've seen a
whole flock of these still i would love
for ahsoka tano to cameo in the series
since presumably obi-wan will have to
leave some babysitter looking after luke
when he leaves tatooine and it would
give a bit more context to ahsoka and
luke's moments in the book of boba fett
then again rosario dawson would be
having to play an ahsoka 20 years
younger than when we've seen her before
i don't know how that would work so on
to the last clip get ashley eckstein
back
[Music]
okay after a close-up of obi-wan we get
the series title which if you look
closely snuck in the shape of obi-wan's
lightsaber on that eye then we hear the
iconic breathing of darth vader and we
know hayden christensen is coming back
in the series to have an epic rematch
with obi-wan kenobi it's super exciting
especially because if you listen closely
they use a specific music sting
this is john williams anakin's dark
deeds track for our revenge of the sith
right after anakin slaughtered the
separatists leaders on moostabar and
bitterly stared into the lava and the
flames a tear rolling down his cheek
a real tear not a digital one
and i love that they remind us of this
moment because for me whenever i rewatch
revenge of the sith this right here was
hayden christensen's darkest performance
just simply his silent glower his inner
torment there is a reason hayden was
brought back for the series because
think about it if they just wanted vader
they could have brought back the team
they used for rogue one james earl jones
doing the voiceover men doing the
performance no they needed hayden
christensen because it's not just darth
vader with the mask that we're returning
to it is the grief-stricken rage-filled
human underneath that mask so this john
williams light motif is a promise that
we will see this face again whether it's
invader's breathing apparatus or a
close-up under the mask the scarred face
or maybe a different form all together
projected in astral form
wow these eyes once more lastly you
gotta love that blue lightsaber cutting
in to form the disney plus logo just
between this and the moon night leap in
the moonlight trailer this is
essentially the house of mouse's new
tinker bell swoosh over the castle and
i'm digging it also check out our great
merch options at new rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
each box follow new rockstars subscribe
to rockstars for more announcements of
everything you love all right thanks for
watching and oh i forgot to say hello
there so um goodbye
there it's gonna get really annoying for
people
when it does these number one videos a
whole bunch of hello there's that's all
you're gonna hear for the next several
months hello there and we're gonna be
part of it too right part of the pro
subscribe to new rock stars leave a like
and hey we'll catch you all soon can't
wait to start reacting to the series it
looks
beautiful